so
before we talk about the various
vaccines for code 19
i'd like to talk to you about censorship
given everything you're saying
why did youtube and other places
sensor discussion of um
ever mectin well there's a question
about why they say they did it
and there's a question about why they
actually did it now
it is worth mentioning that youtube is
part of
a consortium it is partnered with
twitter facebook reuters
ap financial times washington post
some other notable organizations and
that this group has appointed itself
the arbiter of truth in effect they have
decided
to control discussion ostensibly
to prevent the distribution of
misinformation
now how have they chosen to do that in
this case they have chosen
to simply utilize the recommendations of
the who
and the cdc and apply them as if they
are synonymous with scientific truth
problem even at their best
the who and cdc are not scientific
entities they are entities that are
about public health and public health
has
this whether it's right or not and i
believe i disagree with it but it has
this
uh self-assigned right
to lie that comes from the fact that
there is game theory that works against
for example a successful vaccination
campaign
that if everybody else takes a vaccine
and therefore the herd becomes immune
through vaccination
and you decide not to take a vaccine
then you benefit from
the immunity of the herd without having
taken the risk
so people who do best are the people who
opt out
that's a hazard and the who and cdc is
public health entities effectively
oversimplify stories in order that that
game theory does not
cause a predictable tragedy of the
commons
with that said once that right to lie
exists then it finds out
it turns out to serve the interests of
for example pharmaceutical companies
which have emergency use authorizations
that require that there not be a safe
and effective treatment
and have immunity from liability for
harms caused by
their product so that's a recipe for
disaster
right you don't need to be a
sophisticated
uh thinker about complex systems to see
the hazard of immunizing
a company from the harm of its own
product
at the same time that that product can
only exist in the market
if some other product that works better
somehow fails to be noticed
so somehow youtube is doing the bidding
of merck
and others whether it knows that that's
what it's doing i have no idea
i think this may be another case of an
autopilot
that thinks it's doing the right thing
because it's parroting the
corrupt wisdom of the who and the cdc
but the who and the cdc have been
wrong again and again in this pandemic
and the irony here
is that with youtube coming after me
well
my channel has been right where the who
and cdc have been wrong
consistently over the whole pandemic so
how is it that youtube is censoring us
because the who and cdc disagree with us
when in fact
in past disagreements we've been right
and they've been wrong there's so
much to talk about here so
i've heard this many times actually on
the inside of youtube
and with colleagues that i've talked
about talked with
is they kind of in a very casual way say
their
job is simply to slow or prevent the
spread of misinformation
and they say like that's an easy thing
to do
like to know what is true or not is an
easy thing to do
and so from the youtube perspective i
think
they basically outsource
of of the the task of knowing what is
true or not
to public institutions that on a basic
google search claim to be the arbiters
of truth
so if you were youtube who are
exceptionally profitable and
exceptionally powerful
in terms of uh controlling what people
get to see or not
what would you do would you take a stand
a public stand against the whole who
cdc or would you
instead say you know what let's open the
damn
and let any video on anything fly
what do you what do you do here if you
say you were put if brett weinstein was
put in charge
of youtube for a month in this
most critical of times where youtube
actually has incredible amounts of power
to educate the populous uh to give
power of knowledge to the populace such
that they can reform institutions what
would you do how would you run youtube
well unfortunately or fortunately this
is actually
quite simple the founders the american
founders
settled on a counter-intuitive
formulation
that people should be free to say
anything
they should be free from the government
blocking them from doing so
they did not imagine that in formulating
that right
that most of what was said would be of
high quality nor did they imagine it
would be free of harmful things
what they correctly reasoned was that
the benefit
of leaving everything so it can be said
exceeds the cost which everyone
understands to be substantial
what i would say is they could not have
anticipated
the impact the centrality of platforms
like youtube facebook twitter etc
if they had they would not have limited
the first amendment as they did
they clearly understood that the power
of the federal government
was so great that it needed to be
limited
by granting explicitly the right of
citizens to say anything
in fact youtube twitter facebook may be
more powerful
in this moment than the federal
government of their worst nightmares
could have been
the power that these entities have to
control
thought and to shift civilization is so
great
that we need to have those same
protections it doesn't mean that harmful
things won't be said
but it means that nothing has changed
about the cost-benefit analysis
of building the right to censor so if i
were running youtube
the limit of what should be allowed is
the limit of the law
right if what you are doing is legal
then it should not be youtube's place
to limit what gets said or who gets to
hear it
that is between speakers and audience
will harm come from that
of course it will but will net harm come
from it
no i don't believe it will i believe
that allowing everything to be said does
allow a process
in which better ideas do come to the
fore and win out
so you believe that in the end when
there's complete freedom
to share ideas that truth will win out
so what i've noticed just as a brief
side comment
that certain things become viral
irregardless of their truth i i've
noticed that
things that are dramatic and or funny
like things that become memes are not
don't have to be grounded
in truth and so that what worries me
there
is that we basically maximize
for drama versus maximize for truth in a
system where everything is
free and that's worrying in the time of
emergency
well yes it's all worrying in time of
emergency to be sure
but i want you to notice that what
you've happened on is actually an analog
for a much deeper and older problem
human beings are the
we are not a blank slate but we are the
blankest slate that nature has ever
devised and there's a reason for that
right it's where our flexibility
comes from we have
effectively we are robots in which the
a large fraction of the cognitive
capacity has been
or of the behavioral capacity has been
offloaded to the software layer which
gets
written and rewritten over evolutionary
time
that means effectively that much of what
we are
in fact the important part of what we
are is housed in the in the cultural
layer and the conscious layer and not in
the hardware
hard coding layer
that layer is prone to make errors right
and anybody who's watched a child grow
up
knows that children make absurd errors
all the time right that's
part of the process as we were
discussing earlier
it is also true that as you look across
a
field of people discussing things a lot
of what is said is pure nonsense it's
garbage
but the tendency of garbage to
emerge and even to spread in the short
term
does not say that over the long term
what sticks
is not the valuable ideas
so there's a high tendency for uh
novelty to be created in the cultural
space but there's also a high tendency
for it to go extinct
and you have to keep that in mind it's
not like the genome right everything is
happening at a much higher rate
things are being created they're being
destroyed and i can't say
that you know i mean obviously we've
seen totalitarianism arise
many times and it's very destructive
each time it does so it's not like
hey freedom to come up with any idea you
want hasn't produced
a whole lot of carnage but the question
is over time
does it produce more open fairer more
decent
societies and i believe that it does i
can't prove it
but that does seem to be the pattern i i
believe so as well
the thing is in the short term
freedom of speech absolute freedom of
speech can be quite destructive
but you nevertheless have to hold on to
that
because in the long term i think you and
i i guess are optimistic in the sense
that
good ideas will win out i don't know
how strongly i believe that it will work
but i will say i haven't heard a better
idea
yeah i would also point out that there's
something very
significant in this question of the
hubris
involved in imagining that you're going
to improve the discussion by censoring
which is the majority of
concepts at the fringe are nonsense
that's automatic but the
heterodoxy at the fringe which is
indistinguishable
at the beginning from the nonsense ideas
is the key to progress so if you decide
hey the fringe is 99
garbage let's just get rid of it right
hey that's a strong win we're getting
rid of 99
garbage for one percent something or
other and the point is yeah but that one
percent something rather is the key
you're throwing out the key and so
that's what youtube is doing
frankly i think at the point that it
started censoring my channel
you know in the immediate aftermath of
this major reversal of la
for lab league it should have looked at
itself and said well what the hell are
we doing
who are we sensory we're sensory
somebody who was just right
right in a conflict with the very same
people on whose behalf we are now
censoring right that should have caused
them to wake up
so you said one approach if you were on
youtube was just basically
let all videos go that do not violate
the law well i should fix that
okay i believe that that is the basic
principle eric makes an
excellent point about the distinction
between ideas
and personal attacks doxing these other
things so i agree there is
no value in allowing people to destroy
each other's lives
even if there's a technical legal
defense for it
now how you draw that line i don't know
but
you know what i'm talking about is yes
people should be free to traffic in bad
ideas and they should be free to expose
that the ideas are bad
and hopefully that process results in
better ideas winning out yeah there's an
interesting line between
you know like uh ideas like the earth is
flat
which i believe you should not censor
and then like you start to encroach on
like personal attacks
so not not you know doxxing yes but like
not even getting to that like there's a
certain point where it's like
that's no longer ideas that's more
that's somehow not productive even if
it's
it feels like uh believing the earth is
flat it's somehow productive
because maybe this tiny percent chance
it is
you know like it just feels like
personal attacks
it doesn't um well you know it's i'm
torn on this because
there's in this world there's
fraudulent people in this world so
sometimes personal attacks are useful to
reveal that
um but there's a line you can cross
like there's a comedy where people make
fun of
others i think that's amazing that's
very powerful and that's very useful
even if it's painful
but then there's like once it gets to be
um yeah there's a certain line it's a
gray area where you cross where it's no
longer
in any possible world productive and
that's a really weird gray area for
youtube to operate in and it feels like
should be a crowdsourced
thing or people vote on it but then
again do you trust the majority to vote
on what is crossing the line and not i
mean this is where
this is really interesting on this
particular
like the scientific aspect of this do
you think youtube
should take more of a stance not
censoring
but to actually have scientists
within youtube having these kinds of
discussions
and then be able to almost speak out in
a transparent way
this is what we're going to let this
video stand but here's all these other
opinions
almost like take a more active role in
its recommendation system
in trying to present a full picture to
you right now they're not they're
they're the recommender systems are not
human
fine-tuned they're all based on how you
click and there's this clustering
algorithms
they're not taking an active role on
giving you the full spectrum of ideas
in the space of science they just censor
or not
well at the moment it's going to be
pretty hard to compel me
that these people should be trusted with
any sort of
curation or comment on matters of
evidence because they have demonstrated
that they are incapable of doing it well
um you could make such an argument and i
guess i'm open to the idea
of institutions that would look
something like youtube that would be
capable of offering something valuable i
mean and you know even just the fact of
them literally curating things and
putting some videos next to others
you know implies something so
yeah there's a question to be answered
but at the moment no
at the moment what it is doing is quite
literally putting
not only individual humans in tremendous
jeopardy by
censoring discussion of useful tools and
making tools that are
more hazardous than has been
acknowledged seems safe
right but it is also placing humanity in
danger of a
permanent relationship with this
pathogen i cannot emphasize enough
how expensive that is it's effectively
incalculable
if the relationship becomes permanent
the number of people who will ultimately
suffer and die from it is indefinitely
large
yeah there's uh currently the algorithm
is very rabbit hole driven
meaning if you uh if you click on the
flat earth videos that's all you're
going to be presented with
and you're not going to be nicely
presented with arguments against the
flat earth
and the flip side of that
if you watch like quantum mechanics
videos or no general relativity videos
it's very rare you're going to get a
recommendation have you considered the
earth is flat
and i think you should have both same
with vaccine
videos that present the power and
incredible
like biology genetics biology about the
vaccine
you're rarely going to get videos
from well-respected
scientific minds presenting possible
dangers of vaccine and the vice versa is
true as well
which is if you're looking at the
dangers of the vaccine on youtube
you're not going to get the highest
quality of videos recommended to you
and i'm not talking about like manually
inserted cdc videos
that are like the most untrustworthy
things you can possibly watch about how
everybody should take the vaccine it's
the safest thing ever no it's about
incredible again mit colleagues of mine
incredible biologists virologists that
talk about the the details of how the
mrna vaccines work and all those kinds
of things i think
maybe this is me with the ai hat
on is i think the algorithm can fix a
lot of this
and youtube should build better
algorithms and trust that
to and coupled with complete freedom of
speech
to expand the what people are
able to think about present always
varied views not
balanced in some artificial way
hard-coded way
but balanced in a way that's
crowdsourced i think that's an algorithm
problem that can be solved
because then you can delegate it to the
algorithm
as opposed to this hard code
censorship of basically
creating artificial boundaries on what
can and can't be discussed
instead creating a full spectrum of
exploration that can be done
and trusting the intelligence of people
to do the exploration
well there's there's a lot there i would
say we have to keep in mind that we're
talking about
a um a publicly held company with
shareholders and obligations to them and
that that may make it impossible
and i remember um many years ago back in
the early days of google
i remember a sense of terror at the loss
of general search right it used to be
that the that google if you searched
came up with the same thing for everyone
and then
it got personalized and for a while it
was possible to turn off the
personalization
which was still not great because if
everybody else is looking at a
personalized search
and you can tune in to one that isn't
personalized what are
you know that doesn't tell you why the
world is sounding the way
it is but nonetheless it was at least an
option and then that
vanished and the problem is i think this
is literally deranging us
that in effect i mean what you're
describing is unthinkable
it is unthinkable that in the face of
a campaign to vaccine vaccinate people
in order to reach herd immunity
that um youtube would give you
videos on hazards of vaccines
when this is you know how hazardous the
vaccines are is an unsettled
question why is it unthinkable that
doesn't make any sense for what from a
company perspective
if intelligent people in large amounts
are open-minded and are thinking through
the
the the hazards and the benefits of a
vaccine
a company should should find the best
videos
to present what people are thinking
about well let's come up with a
hypothetical
okay let's come up with a a very deadly
disease
for which there's a vaccine that is very
safe
though not perfectly safe and
we are then faced with youtube trying to
figure out what to do for somebody
searching on vaccine safety
suppose it is necessary in order to
drive the pathogen to extinction
something like smallpox
that people get on board with the
vaccine
but there's a tiny fringe of people who
thinks that the vaccine
is a mind control agent
right so should youtube
direct people to the only claims
against this vaccine which is that it's
a mind control agent
when in fact the
vaccine is very safe whatever that means
if that were the actual configuration of
the puzzle
then youtube would be doing active harm
pointing you
to um this other video potentially
now yes i would love to live in a world
where people
are up to the challenge of sorting that
out but
my basic point would be if it's an
evidentiary question
and there is essentially no evidence
that the vaccine is a mind control agent
and there's plenty of evidence that the
vaccine is safe
then well you look for this video we're
going to give you this one
puts it on a par right so for the mind
that's tracking how much
thought is there behind it's safe versus
how much thought is there behind
it's a mind control agent will result in
artificially
elevating this now in the current case
what we've seen
is not this at all we have seen evidence
obscured in order to create a false
story about
safety and we saw the inverse with
ivermectin we saw a campaign
to portray the drug as um
more dangerous and less effective than
the evidence clearly suggested it was
so we're not talking about a comparable
thing but i guess my point is the
algorithmic solution that you point to
um creates a problem of its own which is
that it means
that the way to get exposure is to
generate something
fringy if you're the only thing on some
fringe then suddenly youtube would be
recommending those things and that's
that's obviously a
gameable system at best yeah but the
solution to that
i know you're you're creating a thought
experiment maybe playing a little bit of
a devil's advocate
i think the solution to that is not to
uh limit the algorithm in the case of
the super deadly
virus it's for the scientists to step up
and become better communicators more
charismatic
is fight the battle of ideas
so to create better videos you know the
like if the virus is truly deadly
you have a lot more ammunition a lot
more data a lot more material to work
with in terms of communicating with the
public
it's so be better at communicating and
stop being
you have to start trusting the
intelligence of people and also being
transparent
and playing the game of the internet
which is like what is the internet
hungry for i believe
authenticity stop looking like you're
full of
it's the scientific community if there's
any
flaw that i currently see especially the
people that are in public office
that like uh anthony fauci they look
like they're full of
and i know they're brilliant why don't
they look more authentic
so they're losing that game and i think
a lot of people observing this entire
system now
younger scientists are seeing this
and saying okay if i want to continue
being a
scientist in the public eye and i want
to be effective at my job
i'm going to have to be a lot more
authentic so they're learning the lesson
this evolutionary system is working
uh so there's just a younger generation
of minds coming up that i think will do
a much better job
in this battle of ideas that when the
when the
much more dangerous virus comes along
they'll be able to be better
communicators
at least that's the hope the the using
the algorithm to control that
is uh i feel like is a big problem so
you're going to have the same problem
with a deadly virus
as with the current virus if you let
youtube
draw hard lines by the pr and the
marketing people
versus the broad community of scientists
well in some sense you're you're uh
suggesting something that's
close kin to what i was saying about you
know
freedom of expression ultimately uh
provides an advantage to to better ideas
so i'm in agreement broadly speaking
but i would also say there's probably
some sort of you know let's imagine the
world that you propose
where youtube shows you the alternative
point of view
that has the problem that i suggest but
one thing you could do
is you could give us the tools to
understand what we're looking at
right you could give us so first of all
there's something
i think myopic solipsistic
narcissistic about a an algorithm that
serves
shareholders by showing you what you
want to see rather than what you need to
know
right that's the distinction is
flattering you you know playing to your
blind spot
is something that algorithm will figure
out but it's not healthy for us all to
have
google playing to our blind spot it's
very very dangerous so
what i really want is analytics
that allow me or maybe options and
analytics the
options should allow me to see what
alternative perspectives are being
explored right so here's the thing i'm
searching and it leads me down this road
right let's let's say it's ivermectin
okay
i find all of this evidence that
ivermectin works i find all these
discussions and people talk about
various protocols and this and that and
then i could say all right
what is the other side and i could see
who
is searching not as individuals but what
demographics are searching
alternatives and maybe you could even
combine it with something reddit like
where
effectively let's say that there was a
position that
i don't know that that a vaccine is a
mind control device
and you could have a steel man this
argument
a competition effectively and the better
answers that steal man and as well as
possible
would rise to the top and so you could
read the top three or four
explanations about why this really
credibly is a mind control
uh uh product and you could say well
that doesn't really add up i can check
these three things myself and they can't
possibly be right
right and you could dismiss it and then
as an argument that was credible let's
say
plate tectonics before that was an
accepted concept
you'd say wait a minute there is
evidence
for plate tectonic as crazy as it sounds
that the continents are floating around
on liquid actually that's not so
implausible you know we've got these
subduction
zones we've got a geology that is
compatible
we've got puzzle piece continents that
seem to fit together wow that's a
surprising amount of
evidence for that position so i'm going
to file some bayesian probability with
it that's updated for the fact that
actually the steel man argument's better
than i was expecting
right so i could imagine something like
that where a
i would love the search to be
indifferent to who's searching
right the the solipsistic thing is too
dangerous so
the search could be general so we would
all get a sense for what everybody else
was seeing too
and then some layer that didn't have
anything to do with what
youtube points you to or not but allowed
you to see
you know the general pattern of
adherence to searching for
information and again a layer in which
those things could be defended so you
could hear what a good argument sounded
right
like rather than just hear a caricatured
argument yeah and also reward people
creators that have demonstrated like a
track record of open-mindedness
and correctness correctness as much as
it can be measured over a long term
and sort of i mean
a lot of this maps to
incentivizing good long-term behavior
not immediate kind of dopamine rush
kind of signals
i think ultimately the algorithm
on the individual level should optimize
for personal growth
long-term happiness just
growth intellectually growth in terms of
lifestyle personally and so on as
opposed to
immediate uh i think that's going to
build a better society not even just
like truth because i think
truth is a complicated thing it's more
just you
growing as a person exploring the space
of ideas
changing your mind often increasing the
level to which your open mind and the
knowledge base you're operating from
uh the willingness to empathize with
others all those kinds of things the
algorithm should optimize for
now creating a better human at the
individual level
that you're all i think that's a great
business model
because the person that's using this
tool will then be happier with
themselves for having used it and will
be
a lifelong quote-unquote customer i
think it's a great business model
to make a happy open-minded
knowledgeable
better human being it's a terrible
business model
under the current system what you want
is to build the system in which it is a
great business
model why is it a terrible model uh
because it will be decimated
by those who play to the short term
i don't think so why well i mean i think
we're living it
we're living it well no because if if
you have the alternative that presents
itself
it it it points out the emperor has no
clothes i mean
it points out that youtube is operating
in this way twitter is operating in this
way
so facebook is operating in this way how
long term would you like
the wisdom to to prove that
well even though a week is better what's
currently happening
right but the problem is you know if a
week loses out to an hour
right and i don't think he loses out
he loses out in the short term that's my
point is you're a great communicator and
you basically say
look here's the metrics and a lot of it
is like how people actually feel
like this this is what people experience
with social media
they look back at the previous month and
say
i felt shitty and a lot of days because
of social media right
like if you look back at the previous
few weeks and say
wow i'm a better person because that
month happened
that's they immediately choose the
product that's going to lead to that
that's what love for products looks like
if you if you love
like a lot of people love their tesla
car like that's
or iphone or like beautiful design
that's what love looks like you look
back
i'm a better person for having used this
thing well you got to ask yourself the
question though if this is such a great
business model
why isn't it devolving why don't we see
it
honestly it's competence it's like
people are just it's not
it's not easy to build new it's not easy
to
build products tools systems
on new ideas it's it's kind of a new
idea we've gone through this
everything we're seeing now comes from
the
ideas of the initial birth of the
internet and there just needs to be new
sets of tools they're
uh incentivizing long term personal
growth and happiness
that's it right but but what we have is
a market that doesn't favor this
right i mean for one thing you know we
had an alternative
to facebook right that looked
you know you owned your own data it
wasn't exploitative
and facebook bought a huge interest in
it
and it died i mean who do you know who's
on diaspora
the execution there was not good right
but it could have gotten better
right i don't think that the argument
that
why hasn't somebody done it a good
argument for it's not going to
completely destroy all of twitter and
facebook when somebody does it
or twitter will catch up and pivot to to
the algorithm
this is not what this is not what i'm
saying there's obviously great ideas
that remain
unexplored because nobody has gotten to
the foothill that would allow you to
explore them
that's true but you know an internet
that was non-predatory
is an obvious idea and many of us know
that we want it
and many of us have seen prototypes of
it and we don't move because there's no
audience there so the network effects
cause you to stay with the predatory
internet
but let me just i wasn't kidding about
build the system in which
your idea is a great business plan
um so in our upcoming book heather and i
in our last chapter explore something
called the fourth frontier and fourth
frontier has to do
with sort of a 2.0 version of
civilization which we freely admit
we can't tell you very much about it's
something that would have to be
we would have to prototype our way there
we would have to effectively navigate
our way there
but the result would be very much like
what you're describing it would be
something
that effectively liberates humans
meaningfully
and most importantly it has to feel
like growth without depending on growth
in other words
human beings are creatures that like
every other creature
is effectively looking for growth right
we are looking for
underexploited or unexploited
opportunities and when we find them
our ancestors for example if they
happened into a new valley that was
unexplored by
people their population would grow until
it had carrying capacity so there would
be this great feeling of there's
abundance until you hit carrying
capacity which is inevitable and then
zero-sum dynamics would set in
so in order for human beings to flourish
long term
the way to get there is to satisfy the
desire for growth without hooking it to
actual growth which
only moves in fits and starts and this
is actually i believe the key to
avoiding
these you know spasms of human tragedy
when in the absence of growth
people do uh something that causes their
population to experience growth which is
they go and
make war on or commit genocide against
some other population which is something
we obviously have to
stop by the way this is uh
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century co-authored
that's right with your wife heather
being released to september i believe
you said you're going to do
a little bit of a preview videos on each
chapter leading up to the release
so i'm i'm looking forward to the last
chapter the
as well as well as all the the the
previous one i have a few questions on
that
so you you have um you generally have
faith
to clarify that technology could be the
thing
that empowers this kind of future
well if you just let technology evolve
it's going to be our undoing right
one of the things that i um fault my
libertarian friends
for is this faith that the market is
going to find
solutions without destroying us and my
sense is
i'm a very strong believer in markets
right i believe in their power
even above some market fundamentalists
but what i don't believe
is that they should be allowed to plot
our
course right markets are very good at
figuring out how to do things
they are not good at all about figuring
out what we should do
right what we should want we have to
tell markets what we want and then they
can tell us
how to do it best and if we adopted that
kind of
pro market but in a context where it's
not steering where human well-being is
actually the driver
we can do remarkable things and the
technology that emerges would naturally
be
enhancing of human well-being perfectly
so
no but overwhelmingly so but at the
moment
markets are finding our every defect of
character and exploiting them
and making huge profits and making us
worse to each other
in the process
you